- [Kelly] I love it, I love it.
So, we're just as "Destiny's Child",
I feel like we're the same age.
- [Elisabeth] Yeah.
- So, did you, were you
a "Destiny's Child" fan?
Of course.
- I know, right?
- Of course, all of it.
- I mean like way back, I'm like,
"Bug-A-Boo" days, like way...
- Oh, yes.
- Yes.
- Big, big, big, big.
- Yeah and I'm like,
"They have to have like,
seven sets of lungs with that song".
There's nowhere to breathe.
That was like, that's not fun.
What was your first album, like purchased?
- Oh, you'll like this.
- What?
- Paula Abdul.
(Kelly gasps)
- Paula Abdul?
- Yeah.
- I had...
- An old friend.
- You'll like this, I
had that on cassette.
- Oh, me too.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] It was black.
- I think we are like the same age.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay.
I'm 40.
- 40.
- Oh, boom, oh.
- '82 baby?
- Yes.
- Boom.
- '82.
- Yeah, it was a good year.
- It was a very good year.
- It was a good year, no, that's amazing,
that was one of my firsts, yeah.
- Uh-huh, I had the
cassette and wore it out.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- Oh, my God, I was just
the biggest fan of hers.
I mean, still am, but that
was just revolutionary for me.
And I thought it was so, sort
of like naughty and sassy.
- Of course.
- Remember like, "Cold Hearted Snake".
- Yeah, she was on, on
that video, yes, yes.
- That video, I was like, "Ooh".
And now, when you watch it, it's like...
- Now it's like...
- Nothing.
- So, nothing compared
to what you see now.
(Kelly and Elisabeth laugh)
Yeah, of course.
But you know what's even better?
Is I just remembered,
tapes, like cassettes.
My children will never
know what rewind is.
- Oh, yeah, they won't.
- Like, you know what I'm saying?
Like pressing rewind.
That just hit me, I'm like,
"Now you just go back
to where you wanna go".
You know what I'm saying?
You drag it or something.
- Yeah, if you got lost in
the middle of like a side,
you would've had to go
back and like two songs.
- [Kelly] Rewind, fast
forward, rewind, fast forward.
- It was a journey.
- [Kelly] Yes, it was a journey.
Anyway, I just thought of that.
Was anyone in your family musical?
- Yeah, everyone actually,
no one was in acting
or film or TV or anything.
Everyone was in the
music business with jazz,
jazz and blues.
- Oh, that's intense, okay.
- I know, so, everyone played instruments.
- [Kelly] They're like great musicians.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] If they're playing jazz, yeah.
- Real, real, yeah, real musicians, yeah.
- Well, I heard that you shared
a room with your brother.
- [Elisabeth] Yeah, of course.
- Was that fun since he played music?
Was it...
(Kelly and Elisabeth laugh)
- Good question.
(Kelly chuckles)
I mean, my brother and I are really close.
I love him very much.
So, now I'm nostalgic for the days
that I shared like a room with him.
At the time though, of course,
he was my little brother
and he loved to talk and was very chatty.
So, he would sort of keep
me up all night talking,
which now I'm like, "Oh, I miss that".
But of course at the time, you
know, he kept me all night.
- Yeah and you're like, "Just shut up".
- And then he got a drum set.
- [Kelly] And then he got a drum set?
- And then he got another drum set.
(Kelly laughs)
Multiple drum sets.
And that's when he moved downstairs.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's amazing.
- Underneath my room.
- Oh, that's not so great, that's not,
so, you constantly have the
heartbeat of your brother.
- Exactly, so we got him
the, like electrical drums
with the headphones.
- Oh, with the headphones.
Yes.
- So, it was better, but you
could still hear the like...
(Elisabeth taps)
You know?
- Oh, man.
My poor mom, I played violin.
- Oh, God.
- And not well.
(audience laughs)
Like it was, she was a trooper.
- [Elisabeth] That is brave.
But it was, yeah, it was brave of me.
You grew up in L.A, so...
- Yeah.
- Did doing things like
going to Disneyland,
because I lived in Orange County
for a little bit when I was a kid.
- [Elisabeth] Oh, you did?
- Yeah, like right by Disneyland.
I thought it was so cool
and we went all the time.
- We went all the time.
- Yeah.
- We did not live in Orange County,
we lived in Royal Canyon,
but we went all the time.
It was like 40 minutes away.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Multiple times a year.
- [Kelly] I'm still like a
grownup that loves to go.
- Are you kidding? It's
like my favorite place.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, like my children get excited
and then there's my excitement.
(Elisabeth chuckles)
Yeah.
- I haven't been since the
whole pandemic thing, obviously,
but I used to go every year.
I used to go every year.
And recently in the past like few years,
I discovered that you could get a guide.
So, if you like pool,
a bunch of friends...
- Life changing.
- Game changer.
- Yes.
- So, it's not like cheap,
but if you get like,
five, six, seven people
and you all pool your money,
like you can get this guide.
- Yes.
- [Elisabeth] Who basically,
like gets you through the lines
and what's great is you
focus on their rides.
You get on more rides,
which is the objective.
- Yes, but so, what's not great though,
is that you go, this is
a first world problem,
but they put you on the ride so fast.
- [Elisabeth] Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That your body never has the hour or two
that you're usually waiting in the lines.
- [Elisabeth] Yes, so like...
- So, your body, so then all
of a sudden you're like...
(Kelly groans)
Like, like, you know,
you're about to barf.
(Elisabeth laughs)
- I used to be able to ride Space Mountain
like, multiple times in a row.
- [Kelly] Tops, two for me.
- And now I'm like, "I
don't think I'm good".
- Yeah.
- I don't think I'm good.
- And I have to like, I'm so old,
I have to like planned food around like,
when I can ride or not ride.
(Kelly and Elisabeth chuckle)
- Yeah.
- I'm like, "It'll come back up".
- Absolutely, absolutely.
- [Kelly] Well, that's a great age.
(audience applauds)
That was a look at season
five of "The Handmaid's Tale".
You can see it now on Hulu.
The show, for those who don't know,
is about a dystopian world
in which the United States
has split forming a country called Gilead,
in which citizens are forced
to play specific roles.
So, your character, June
has escaped Gilead like four times.
So, where do we find her this season?
- I am not in Gilead.
- Okay.
- At the top of the
season, I am in Canada.
She's trying to kind of recover
from the terrible sort of murder that her
and her friends committed
at the end of last season.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I like bringing these
stories to your daytime show.
- Yeah, we just like to cheer
people up here, Elisabeth.
Yeah, yeah.
- Afternoon.
(Kelly chuckles)
So, she's recovering from that
and she's also trying to figure out
how to be a mother and a
wife and a human and a woman.
And also, be somebody who has
gone through extreme trauma.
- So, like a lot of people
now, like that's, yeah,
that's a very relatable thing, so...
- [Elisabeth] It can be, very much so.
- Yeah.
- So, what perspective
has the series given you
on what's been going on with women
and women's rights and
everything right now?
I mean...
- Because it's kind of eerie.
- Yeah, I liked your documentary.
(Kelly chuckles)
- [Kelly] That was, that
was Jordan, our writer.
It was very funny.
- It was good.
- Yeah.
- You know, I mean as
a human and as a woman
and a citizen, of course,
I have my own feelings
and my own, you know,
what I think is right
and what I think is wrong.
- Yeah.
- When you're a part of a show like that,
of course you get so much more of it
and it's a part of your everyday life.
And you're living out these scenarios.
- [Kelly] You're faced with it.
- You're faced with it every day
and you're having conversations
every day about it,
in a, in a really deep way,
which I have found very fulfilling
and I have found very eye
opening and very educating,
because now a lot of people come to me,
a lot of people share things with me.
I hear people's stories
and from all over the world
and it's, it's been a very
gratifying experience as a woman.
- Yeah, I love the direct impact.
I think that that's when people do learn
and progress, is you have
some kind of direct impact
to whatever that cause is or
whatever thing is happening.
- [Elisabeth] Yeah.
- And I think that's important.
- It is and you know, we're telling...
- That's why I think this
kind of series is important.
- Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, you know, we're telling
our story through one lens.
We're telling it through June's lens.
It's called, "The Handmaid's Tale".
It's her story, but I hope,
and what has happened,
I hope continues to happen,
is it does continue to open up the space
for other people to share their stories,
whether they're similar or not.
And other people from other
walks of life and other...
- [Kelly] Other perspectives.
- Exactly, other perspectives.
And I, I really enjoy and
value that conversation.
- I do too, I love conversation.
Especially, I love being at a
table when people don't agree.
[Elisabeth] Yes.
- Because I find that exciting,
because you learn something.
- [Elisabeth] Absolutely.
- And it, and it, it just,
I love those kind of conversations.
Most people don't, but I do,
or most people I'm around don't.
- Yeah.
- But I, but I do, I love it.
I genuinely get excited about it.
- That's how you learn.
- So, you are, I, I love this.
You're directing again.
- Yeah.
I think that's exciting.
- [Elisabeth] Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Not every actor wants
to do all the things
and I think that's really cool,
that you love like, challenging yourself.
So, what's it like directing?
Bradley, like y'all worked
together on "West Wing",
so, is that weird?
Because you were very
young on "West Wing".
- [Elisabeth] Yeah, I
was 17 when I met him
and he was my age when he met me.
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
- [Elisabeth] Which is crazy.
- Do you remind him and
make him feel old for that?
(Kelly chuckles)
- All the time, all the time.
No, he's just, I mean we
have a very close friendship.
We're like very, we're
really close, personal
and professional, like partnership.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Elisabeth] But he, he
directed this year too
and oh, we have to explain these photos.
Okay so, he directed this
year and he did episode nine.
And he was like, "Can I
shadow? I wanna like..."
And I was like, "I don't
know what you're gonna learn
from me, but okay Bradley Whitford,
come on and try to follow
me around for a bit".
And I put him to work, I put him to work.
I made him play every character
in "The Handmaid's Tale".
I made him learn all the lines,
I made him stand in for me.
And so those pictures,
I don't know if they
could show them again,
but those pictures are him,
Bradley Whitford, television legend,
multiple award winner...
- I love that.
- [Elisabeth] Been in
every movie, basically...
- [Kelly] Look at his, look at his eyes.
- [Elisabeth] Working for me.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- [Elisabeth] Look at how bored he looks.
He's looking at like, Twitter.
- [Kelly] You should
just frame all of these
and send them to him for
like Christmas or something.
(audience chuckles)
- [Elisabeth] I totally
should make like an album.
- [Kelly] It would me nervous though,
like with a friend, to be like,
to have to like kind of be
the boss in the situation.
That makes me nervous.
- Really?
- [Kelly] Yeah, it does.
Even now, like I've been
friends with these guys
for like, well most of them,
like 20 years, or 10 plus.
And it's weird for me to have to be like,
"Hey, let's do the, it's..."
I'm not good at like,
I don't like leading.
Although, I have to
sometimes, I don't like it.
Do you enjoy that?
- I don't mind it.
- [Kelly] Oh, really?
I don't enjoy it.
- That's so interesting.
- No.
- I wouldn't expect that.
- I love following.
- That's so interesting.
- I love it, yeah.
Ask any of my friends, I don't
like to make any decision.
- [Elisabeth] Really?
- Where do you wanna go to eat?
What do you wanna watch?
(audience chuckles)
- [Elisabeth] That's so interesting.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I kind of like leading.
- [Kelly] Nope, nope.
(Elisabeth laughs)
- [Kelly] But I have
to like, all the time.
- You have to all the time,
that's what surprises me.
- It drives me nuts.
- But you're very good
at it, I would imagine.
- You're very nice.
- I mean, your show's successful.
- Just a bunch of people behind
the scenes, making it work.
- That is true though.
- [Kelly] It is true.
- It is true, like leading is kind of,
there are times when you
have to make the decision
and you have to say what needs to be done.
But a lot of the time it's
partnership and collaboration
and that's how I feel
like, you know, with Brad.
I don't feel like I'm leading him.
I feel like we're partnering
and that's the best place to be.
- Maybe, that's the best
kind of leader, yes.
- [Elisabeth] Ooh, well maybe.
- Yes, nicely done.
(Kelly chuckles)